[Music]
we gotta talk about this dress to begin
what my gosh this is gorgeous
remember the name - and very proud of
myself yuju you Nina couture oh you did
it like easy you know you didn't trip on
it or anything five times before I got a
pair so we're good it's beautiful thank
you thank you gotta make it's like a
whole extra person long hair my spouse
was like that is not happening it's
gonna compete so she gave me a bow bow
yeah well that works yeah it's really
pretty no did you know when you put this
on I mean I think I wrote it anyway I
just tried this on I was like done I
don't like to do the whole 10-hour
dress-up game I'm like finished it
should be that's beautiful I mean
fantastic so I had its ability to be
here tonight this is six months after
the shooting at Vegas - I mean I know
they're gonna do a whole thing for the
the beginning of the show which i think
is beautiful
there's no music which i think is very
special and it's usually like you open
up a show and it's all about the music
and I think now it's all about those
victims and their families and I think
that's really nice that's gonna be a
very impactful and uh you know just to
be here is incredible and seeing all
these people I've never been in the
country world so it's been very
different awesome
well the country world works well for
you yeah yeah it was like first country
song out it's been really amazing you
know so are you gonna do more with
Florida Georgia line uh you know I'm Joe
they're amazing guys but I have some
other things on the work so on my album
so see them any other country
collaboration yes oh really
yeah give us a hint male female male
male yeah group solo solo and yeah cuz
I'm finishing my own expectations and he
heard one songs and he's like I want to
be on it and I was like okay why not
he's really awesome alright you were on
American Idol I look Brian is on
American Idol he's like he like gave me
the talk the rough talk he's like now
it's like welcome to my world I was like
oh and he was like giving me to talk
he's like and I feel like I had to like
I was like I had to be like you know
like it's not like fraternities where
you have to kind of or whatever whatever
you call it when they take on a hazing
kind of man gonna behave okay you know
felt like it was like one step away I
was like oh my god she's so scared but
he was really nice you know so he's not
the one that you're doing a
collaboration with no yeah I would have
been perfect cuz you're on Idol yeah
Luke was there
darn it was fun I'm ever gonna hold was
really really fun so out of good time I
can't wait to find out who it is yeah
it's really awesome you look fantastic
beautiful it's so good to see you